michael bisping michael bisping
was also one that was good at getting
under people's skin right very good yes
somebody said here he admitted he
imitated you do you know how to imitate
him
you bloody bastard
what a prick
i i was with mike bisping quite recently
i was in manchester we had a drink
together it was really it was recently
yeah we didn't have like a movie or
documentary come out about his life
where it is it's very good yeah it's
very good and he is he's a lot of fun to
hang out with i mean
yeah yeah i mean i mean
a lot of stuff have has been said but i
i i
behind
all these
fugazi things is there's a human and i
always have a good time catching up with
some of my old adversary
anybody you guys that you guys don't get
along till today or no everybody is
saying there's nobody today there's
absolutely nobody that i've fought that
if i let's say i would drive my car and
i would see them on the side side having
a problem i would stop for every one of
them you have no beef no beef wouldn't
and i don't i and i don't think anybody
has beef with me i don't think so
all the stuff that have been said and
done even if it was very edgy it was
only for business for me it's not
personal so the next trip is you got to
take a trip to stockton california
even
i wish i'm the best of luck and
everything i don't hold any grudge
nothing i i really do i really wish him
i hope if he come decides to come to
come back and he did last time he didn't
look good but i i hope if he does it for
the right reason he has the motivation i
wish him the best i wish him that i
loved watching those guys fight was
there anybody when you were coming up
you watched fight that you said dude
this guy
had the goodies to become very very
great like was there anyone that you
felt we never saw the best of him
when he was coming up same era as you
there's a lot of guys a lot of guys i've
seen especially in the gym that are that
were very talented very good but they
never made it
because they
i don't know if it's mentally they they
couldn't
pull the trigger they there's a lot of
these guys like you just talk about
there's a lot of these guys so that's
why it's like a funnel there's so many
guys that has potential but
it when you narrow it down there's only
one that made it sometimes the stars are
just aligned better for one guy i i
don't know i i'm you know i believe like
people are like oh yeah you work hard
but you made your yes but it's not
necessarily true i don't agree with that
a hundred percent i believe there's a
lot of
i believe in the causality i believe
there is cause and effect and that i
believe
our ignorance
sometimes made it in a way that we call
certain things chances but i don't
believe there is chances i believe it's
there's always a cause and by definition
if there is a cause there is
no free will in a way it's kind of weird
to think about it but that's always
almost like we got a our own ufc
philosopher uh on our head i told you
he's deep so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]